[Musique]
game watch
est-ce que tu connaisses est si je crée
par nintendo au début des années 80 le
principe de game watch est hyper sympa
un petit jeu qui est très facile
d'utilisation qui est très simple game
watch a existé de 1981 à 1991
ça fait partie des premiers jeux
électroniques qui ont existé et des
premiers jeux nintendo bien avant la
game boy bien avant la nes quelque part
la game watch fait partie des ancêtres
du jeu vidéo
la game watch c'est vraiment un truc qui
a cartonné kate est vendu en tout à plus
de 40 millions d'exemplaires dans le
monde entier à l'époque il n'y avait pas
de game boy n'y avait pas de jeu il n'y
avait pas de téléphone portable et puis
les gens forcément n'avait pas grand
chose pour se divertir je dirais que
tout ce qui concernait le numérique il
ya eu quelques ébauches de jeu truc un
petit peu pourri mais ça c'est vraiment
le premier jeu du diction pas vraiment
tous les ingrédients là dedans c'est à
dire que tu as une case jeetah une case
mariottat des petits tronçons de bois ou
de je ne sais pas quoi qui arrive à
mario mario ne l'est pas saliji luigi
les montées à étages supérieurs et on
n'utilise pas ça mario sauf qu'en
attendant il ya des jeunes qui arrivent
la cadence s'accélère et il ne faut pas
les mettre à côté ou pas les échappées
sinon on se fait engueuler par le patron
temps lui faut que je monte ma maman si
c'est le cas au top au lieu dit la haut
et dans le camion voilà le principe du
game watch avec plein de petits jeux
comme ça hein donc quiconque 2 tu doit
délivrer donc et contient rossi qui est
enchaîné et toi tu passes par en bas
dont il joue sur le deux écrans ça te
rappelle pas un petit peu des consoles
nintendo sa belle-soeur de trucs mario
alors celui-là il s'appelle mario simone
factory [ __ ] ça le monde allait se
montra messam écrase très sympa en mono
écran celui là je ne sais pas c'est un
petit trésor si tu veux à ses tout
premiers donkey kong génial ça c'est un
trésor si tu veux c'est un pote à moi
qu'il les a retrouvés et à qui j'ai
forcément demandé de me les prêter
taiana que j'ai j'aime et qui dans ma
cave en bas c'est le green house gdv
rend au g20 à la vache tu as quand même
vrai niveau de difficulté là dedans 1982
j'ai joué quand j'étais gamin ça alors
pendant 82 j'avais deux ans mais un
petit peu plus tard effectivement j'ai
joué à ça le bon vieux
ball pareil un flipper de deux crans à
les gens voient une autre boule c'est
parti mon kiki
allez on y va en grimpant ravon un jeune
ivoirien owell la boule le tropical fish
qui est très sympa parce que tu as la
boîte qui est vraiment juste top et
l'état est vraiment génial assure un
trappe les poissons qui sortent de l'eau
à fait d'accord est d'accord tout
laissait passer d'un aquarium à l'autre
c'est tous des jeux si tu veux qu'ils
ont gardé une certaine valeur green
house ça vaut 70 euros en valeur
actuelle d'occasion tu peux le vendre 70
euros si tu as la boîte forcément
c'était le packaging qu'il vendra plus
cher
le paintball à 50 euros le mario bros à
50 euros c'est le prix bien sûr son la
boîte l'état fonctionnel sans être
abîmée le don qui compte 2 à 80 euros
tropical fiche 80 euros sans la boîte
avec la boîte tu peux le vendre beaucoup
plus tu peux en tirer même 200 euros
sans aucun problème c'est toute la botte
est allé nickel mario simons factory
sahara 100 euros c'est à dire que en
réalité dans ma petite boîte j'ai pour
le prix d'une bouteille de switch avec
tous ces petits trucs là c'est dingue
est le tout premier donkey kong sait
même pas comment ils vont alors celui-là
il est pas en bon état mais ça doit
coûter aussi peut-être plus facilement
100 euros c'est vraiment des produits
qui sont top
alors c'est sûr que par rapport à ce qui
se fait aujourd'hui ces jeux là ça va te
paraître carrément désuet il faut
vraiment se remettre dans le contexte de
l'époque tu es au début des années 80
pendant dix ans ces jeux là je dirais
ont régné en maître avec une concurrence
qui s'est développé au fur et à mesure
y'avait pas les éditions connaissait pas
les jeux comme aujourd'hui et on était
très très très loin d'avoir ce genre de
choses autant dire que on a fait dans la
préhistoire du jeu vidéo mais ça a un
côté qui est hyper sympa parce que tu te
retrouves avec des jeux si tu veux
qu'ils racontent des histoires et pas
juste sur un petit nid peur avec un trou
qu'ils valent
ça raconte l'histoire de luigi et son
frère alors effectivement voté un petit
peu capitaliste productivité sinon non
seulement gueuler par le patron bon
travail up rempli [ __ ] ça par exemple
sur la bouche
je crois me souvenir que c'est des
petits insectes qui viennent et qui ont
embêté le jardinier donc il faut les
nettoyer pour entretenir son jardin et
c'était vraiment d
jeux super sympa en tout cas l'époque
comme tu avais pas d'autre je n'avais
pas de comparatif ça c'était génial je
me rappelle quand j'étais gamin comme en
mer en acheter un c'était la fête tu
t'éclates et avait un nouveau jeu et
puis c'était vraiment la révolution
parce que il n'y avait rien dit sur le
marché il est vite que ça qui existaient
et c'était génial
bon voilà c'est fini un peu pour cette
petite vidéo revival a représenté des
produits d'un autre temps mais qui mine
de rien je pense peuvent revenir au goût
du jour
ne serait ce que pour les vrais fans de
jeux vidéo puis se combinent se balade
des trucs un peu ludique alors
effectivement c'est hyper basique c'est
vraiment hyper hyper simple et puis bon
je pense qu'on a fait le tour rapidement
mais pour ceux qui veulent se marier
retrouver dans le vintage c'est vraiment
des jeux qui raconte une histoire
mais moi toi en commentaire dis moi si
tu connais un petit peu ces jeux si les
game & watch a découvert
peut-être que tu es un peu de l'ancienne
école comme moi qui fais partie des plus
anciens et a pu tester tu as pu jouer
mais watch si c'est pas le cas des
kuchis tijd en tout cas les découvrir si
tu as pu les essayer les découvrir même
si t'es pas de l'époque mais moi un
commentaire dis moi ce que t'en pense
dit moi je t'aimerai les essayer et puis
on partage un peu notre expérience
merci beaucoup tu peux aussi regarder
cette vidéo tu peux tu abonnés ça me
ferait très plaisir n'hésite pas à
lâcher un pouce bleus si la vidéo tu as
plus je t'en remercie puis c'est à dire
très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
ciao